welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Steven Roach a senior fellow and
senior lecturer with the Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs and Yale
School of Management mr. Roach has spent
28 years in senior positions at Morgan
Stanley the bulk of that time as chief
economist and more recently as chairman
of the firm's Asian businesses in
addition to his position at Yale he
remains the non-executive chairman of
Morgan Stanley Asia mr. Roach has long
been one of Wall Street's most
influential economists his most recent
book the next Asia opportunities and
challenges for a new globalization
analyzes Asia's economic imbalances and
the dangers of the region's dependence
on Western consumers today we'll talk
with mr. Roche about the future of China
and what it means for the global economy
welcome mr. Roche good to see you
Maryland in the past 30 years or so
China has experienced unprecedented
economic development let's talk about
that for a little bit and if you can
give us an overview of what has happened
well you go back 30 years ago Maryland
China Post Cultural Revolution the
economy was on the brink of collapse and
then a series of reforms were instituted
under the leadership of done shopping
and the economy is recorded on average
about 10% growth a year for three
decades predominantly led by two key
sectors exports and export led fixed
investment and the growth rate has truly
been spectacular the increases in the
standard of living the income for the
average Chinese has moved up tenfold
over that period no country has ever
experienced a development miracle like
that
the question that I raised and the
question that I address in my new course
at Yale the next China is is is this
model sustainable and Mike
conclusion which we can talk about in
greater detail is that there needs to be
some big changes in China's approach to
economic growth and development okay and
what are those changes
well the main change is that China has
to figure out the policies that needs to
put in place to stimulate internal
private consumption the model as it is
been evident over the past 30 years is
hugely dependent on not just China's own
competitiveness in the global economy
but on the state of global demand and in
the aftermath of this devastating
financial crisis that's the big question
mark the clouds that horizon
consumers in America Europe Japan are
going to be much less dynamic and
supporting the external demand that
underpins the Chinese export machine so
lacking in that support from the broader
global economy China needs a new source
of growth and that growth has got to
come from its 1.3 billion people in the
form of a significant increase in
internal private consumption okay you
recently wrote an op-ed piece for The
New York Times and you know you cite
some challenges for the US government
and then also there are some tensions
some some similar tensions that are
similar between the two countries let's
talk about a little bit about that well
China's the whipping boy for the
post-crisis world especially in in the
US where we have a horrific unemployment
and underemployment problem that
involves between 16 to 17 percent of the
entire American working age population
and for those Americans who are still
working their wages adjusted for
inflation have really not grown much for
the median American worker in the last
decade and unfortunately you know we
have a pretty poisonous political
climate in this country and and our
politicians in Washington don't want to
accept any responsibility for
or these problems bearing down on
American middle-class workers so they
blame globalization they blame the trade
deficit they blame the biggest piece of
our trade deficits with China they
conclude that China manipulates its
currency and therefore we should put
enormous pressure on China to revalue
the remin be sharply higher if they
don't let's slap them with trade
sanctions this is the view in Washington
the US House of Representatives enacted
a bill that would impose trade sanctions
on China if it doesn't follow this
recipe and yet unfortunately I believe
this whole analysis this prescription is
dead wrong
it reflects America's unwillingness to
look in the mirror and figure out what
really causes the savings problem and
what we must do as a nation to address
that okay so what do you think the
United States should do and what do you
think China should be doing in terms of
working together to try and resolve
these issues well from the US point of
view it's not that difficult to figure
out that we don't have just a china
problem if you look at our trade
statistics last year 2009 we had trade
deficits with 90 countries that's nine
zero that means excluding China we had
deficits with 89 other countries we have
a multilateral trade imbalance not a
bilateral trade problem simple math
simple economics tells you it's pretty
logical that you don't fix a
multilateral problem with a so-called
bilateral fix the reason we have a
multilateral trade deficit in the United
States is for one simple reason we do
not save lacking and saving we must
import surplus savings from abroad in
order to grow and run huge current
account and multilateral trade
imbalances to attract the capital if we
want to fix our trade problems with
China or with the other 89 countries we
were on deficits with we've got to
figure out how to save again and that
means we've got to control our budget
deficit eventually and encourage
American families to save the
old-fashioned way which they gave up
doing during the era of
excess when we saved out of asset
bubbles so these are our problems these
are not China's problems in the same
sense China must be responsible for its
surplus saving which has certainly
played a role in creating major global
imbalances and it must put in place
policies to stimulate an internal
private consumption I wrote about that
in detail in the New York time it's very
specific recommendations as to what I
think China needs to do and what what
are those recommendations well you have
to start with the idea that China's
consumption share of its GDP is only
about 36% right now and amazingly enough
that's about half the the ratio that
exists in the US so you know we consume
too much they consume too little there
are three things that need to be done
explicitly by the Chinese to boost
internal private consumption first and
foremost they have to invest in a social
safety net this is social security
private pensions unemployment insurance
medical insurance they do that they will
draw down the excesses of fear driven
precautionary saving number two they
have to provide a lot of support to
rural income still 750 million Chinese
live at relatively impoverished levels
in the rural countryside so aggressive
tax policy rural land reform IT enabled
connectivity and policies that encourage
rural urban migration need to be
emphasized the third and finally believe
it or not China despite all its growth
doesn't generate enough jobs and that's
because most of the growth is driven by
a manufacturing sector where you boost
productivity by substituting machines
for people China has a very small and
undeveloped services sector which is a
much more labor intensive endeavor of
economic activity and it needs to
promote policies that would encourage
the expansion of industries like
wholesale trade retail trade healthcare
hospitality leisure domestic
transportation you put those policies in
place and I'm very optimistic that China
will do that in its upcoming 12th
five-year plan to be enacted early next
year and the consumption share will move
the idea you can achieve that by a
currency revaluation on the part of
China
I think is ludicrous and far-fetched at
best okay do you think that currency
revaluation will happen though
nevertheless the Chinese have been since
the middle of 2005 been allowing their
currency the renminbi or some people
refer to it as you want to move up
gradually visa vie the dollar it's up
since the middle of 2005 a five year
period about 23% against the dollar
by the way when American congressman
first started bashing China back in
nineteen in 2005 they said that the
Chinese renminbi was 25% undervalued
against the dollar the dollar is up 23
of those 25 points they are still saying
that the remedy is 25% undervalued I
think their models are stuck they need
to sort of reboot the Machine and figure
out a new way to calculate these
so-called valuation metrics okay in
looking at China again is there are
there any specifics that China can do to
help struggling United States there's a
huge one if China succeeds in
implementing the policies that I just
enumerated and they boost their internal
private consumption as a share of u.s.
GDP that is an enormous opportunity for
American companies that export into
China is America's third largest export
market today the Obama administration
desperate for new sources of economic
growth has identified exports as a main
target for economic growth they feel
strongly that exports have the potential
to double over the next five years and
this would create millions of new jobs I
agree with that I think that's a very
ambitious but realistic target but how
are we going to double export markets if
we slap trade sanctions on the economy
that is our third largest export market
most likely they would
reciprocal sanctions on American goods
sold there if we encourage China to
boost internal private consumption then
we've got a shot to compete into that
market our third largest export market
and grow our way back to prosperity
rather than try to bash China as a
recipe for prosperity there's no way
we're going to achieve those goals if we
impose trade sanctions on China but if
we encourage China and put pressure on
them to open up their markets and grow
their internal demand that's an
extraordinary competitive opportunity
for the United States ok and let's look
at the next two Asia
five ten years down the road what does
it look like to me the next Asia will be
a more balanced Asia one that derives
much greater support from Asia's most
precious asset it's arena half billion
consumers the Asian a growth machine for
most of the last 3040 years has been
export led hugely dependent on demand in
the developed world that demand is now
tired it needs a rest that's what the
crisis is telling you and so it's it's
time for Asia given the amazing success
that the region has accomplished
especially China in figuring out and how
to crack the code of economic
development it's time for the region to
really put in place the types of
policies that I have elaborated on it
would stimulate its own internal markets
Asia will then be a more balanced
economy it will be a an economy that
derives much greater support from its
services sector less reliant on natural
resources as a result less of a polluter
in the world and this will be important
for a
village that is focused on climate
change and cleaner world GDP growth very
good thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work it's a pleasure to be with you
mural for more information about
professor Roach and his work please
visit our website at yale.edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale